20-year-olds stay poor because they
start trying to earn rather than trying
to learn they don't realize the season
they're in and they do it out of order
and so they try and go and right hook
life and get as much they possibly can
rather than realizing that when a
business is trading with you the only
thing you're getting paid for isn't just
money you also get paid with experience
and if you're the one who's coming in
with all the experience guess what
you're not getting paid with experience
from other people if you come in for
half the price in terms of your salary
at a company that has a way better
reputation way more people ahead of you
you will get paid less in the short run
in money but you will get paid more
longterm in skills